T
REALLY MATTER WHAT WE THINK OF A
NEW WE ARE THE HAVE-NOTS IN
JOINING ME NOW FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR IN WASHINGTON TIMES
OPINION EDITOR CHARLIE THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US FIRST QUESTION,
THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC WAS REALLY
A BOON FOR THE HAVES WAS NIGHT,
THE TECH COMPANIES AND THAT
TEACHING UNIONS AND GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS TO 12 ARE WE GOT
SCREWED.
CHARLIE: I THINK IT WILL TAKE
DECADES OF SETTING A SARAH THIS
TO TWO YEARS BEFORE WE FULLY
CALCULATE JUST HOW MUCH THIS WAS
A HUGE BOON FOR PEOPLE POWER I
THINK YOU ARE ONE OF THE FIRST
ONES TO DETECT THIS OR AT THE
VERY BEGINNING FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE I THINK IT WAS ABOUT
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT BUT VERY
QUICKLY BECAME SOMETHING ALL
ABOUT POWER FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK IN CONGRESS IMAGING LIKE
DEMOCRATS.
IN THE USER TO MAKE THEMSELVES
MORE POWERFUL AND TO MAKE THE
GOVERNMENT MORE POWERFUL AND
RICH THEIR DONORS AND A HIJACKED
THE ELECTION AND TO DESTROY
TRUMP WHICH OF COURSE WAS THE
BIGGEST GOAL OF ALL AND WHAT IS
SO DISTURBING ABOUT IT IS
THEY'VE WON, IT WORKED SO
ANYBODY WHO THINKS THAT THE
LESSON FROM THIS FOR THEM AS
ANYTHING OTHER THAN LET'S DO IT
AGAIN, YOU'RE SADLY MISTAKEN
BECAUSE I GUARANTEE YOU THAT THE
ONLY METHOD THEY TOOK OUT OF
THIS, IS THAT IT WORKED.
>> THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT
CHARLIE AND I REALIZED EARLY ON
THAT THEY LEAVE US ON THE LEFT
IS CONTROL, THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN
THE THOUSAND THE MANDATES WORK
FOR THEM, YOU MEAN TAKING MY
BIDEN SOVEREIGNTY THROUGH THE
MANDATES AND EMPOWERING
GOVERNMENT, HE ALSO HAVE
INTERESTING THOUGHTS ON THE
TRUMP ELECTION IN THE HAVE-NOTS,
WHY TRUMP ATTRACTED A LOT OF
THESE HAVE-NOTS IT IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE MESSAGE, AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES IN YOUR NOTES
ON THIS INTERESTING.
CHARLIE: IN THESE VERY
INTERESTING TO ADD TRUMP FIRST
CAME ON ABOUT THE REASON SO MANY
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON DID I LIKE
HIM WAS BECAUSE HE IS ALL ABOUT
STYLE, HE WAS NOT ABOUT STYLE
AND ALL THAT I NOW REALIZE THAT
TO BE CLICKABLE THEY DO NOT LIKE
HIS STYLE, THEY LOW THE REGULAR
AMERICANS BUT THE REAL ISSUE
THEY HAVE WITH HIM WAS THE
ISSUES THAT DONALD TRUMP AND
TRUMP ALONE HAD IDENTIFIED THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE REPUBLICANS
HAD IGNORED FOR YEARS LIKE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND LIKE THE
COLLAPSE OF OUR MIDDLE-CLASS
LIKE THE COLLAPSE OF HER
INDUSTRY IN THIS COUNTRY AND
SETTING UP TO CHINA PENALTIES
ISSUES THAT BOTH PARTIES HAD
IGNORED FOR SO LONG.
AND HE IDENTIFIED THEM AND HE
REALIZED THEN OF COURSE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
I AGREE WITH HIM ON ALL OF THESE
ISSUES AND IRRESPECTIVE OF IF
PARTY OR ALL OF THE FAKE RACIAL
DELINEATIONS OF THE POLITICIANS
TRY TO FIND EVERYBODY UP AND,
DOES BILL THINK THAT THEY FEARED
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP WAS THAT HE
WAS ONTO STUFF IN A LIST OF THE
ISSUES THAT ACTUALLY MATTER TO
PEOPLE IF YOU GO BACK TO 2015,
ELECTION, I'VE ALWAYS SAID THIS
AND I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
TRUE, IT WAS THE MOST ISSUE
ORIENTED ELECTION OF OUR
LIFETIME THERE'S BEEN NO OTHER
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THAT WAS
MORE BASED ON THE ISSUES AND HE
DID NOT GET ELECTED BY BEING A
NICE GUY, HE GOT ELECTED BECAUSE
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT ISSUES THAT
THE POLITICIANS